même à paris on trouve des vignerons
plutôt des viticulteurs amateurs qui
font pousser des pieds de vigne dans
leur jardin ou sur leur balcon
aujourd'hui ils ont apporté leur récolte
à l'association les vignerons de paris
cela se passait dans la mairie du xième
philippe panis christian welter devrait
avoir tout de suite ces sujets sous ses
pieds
les raisins des 150 vignerons de paris
origine 100 % intra muros balcons
terrasses et rebords de fenêtres
production de 70 kg pour le plus gros
récoltant à deux grappes pour daniel
viticulteurs débutant à ménilmontant
cinq ans donc c'est la première année où
a trait aux grappes paris en bouteille
en 1992 la première cuvée des vignerons
de la capitale avait permis de remplir
597 bouteille faible quantité et qualité
disons supérieur on parie ses meilleurs
vins du monde pourquoi pas convaincu ou
non des centaines de parisiens étaient
venus ce matin retirer leurs pieds de
vigne distribution gratuite de ses pages
en tout genre je vais planter ses pieds
son balcon
parce que j'adore la chlorophylle et on
en a besoin paris et avoir du temps pour
mon petit-fils plus tard parce que moi
je le verrais pas je crois pas non alors
paris futurs grands vignobles
in vino veritas